want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got so much more inside
you you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only robert kiyosaki enjoy
the basic skill on this side according
to my rich dad
was you have to sell
you cannot be an entrepreneur if you
cannot sell yeah
and that scared the crap out of me
because um
you know i'm japanese i'm really i'm
really a shy person
and my rich head looked to me and he
says you're shy huh big
deal what are you going to do about it
i said well you know i just don't you
know i just i just like don't like
rejection i don't like this i don't like
that and i could kill people
but i couldn't talk to them
so my rich dad's pressuring me says
i said i don't want to sell because on
my poor dad's side you know the japanese
side
salesmen are scum salesmen are crooks
salesmen are con men
and on this side sales you have to have
the ability to sell can you handle
rejection
can you somebody say no to you and can
you come back
and i didn't want to do that i'm very
shy person so he says that shyness is
killing you hey robert what advice would
you give a 20 year old man who is
starting his entrepreneurial career
start
i mean uh study study study study study
i mean what accumulates you know fat
accumulates
but so does knowledge and wisdom
and so i could be sitting at a bar you
know instead of listening to a rich
cooper or rallo i keep a thing in a bar
sucking down chicken wings and a
budweiser
that accumulates or i could be listening
to youtube and listen to you guys and
listen to gammon and listen to guys like
records and
i'll also listen to the marxists some of
these guys they give me the creeps
there's a lot of marxists and communists
on youtube well you have to know your
enemy right i mean you have to know what
they're plotting
it's called keep an open mind you know
one of the biggest mistakes i still hear
it today
from young people oh
i don't have to worry because i'm still
young yeah and that is death to most
people
because eventually you get old and then
you're not young again so it's a way of
saying we talk about assets and
liabilities
one of the most important things you
have in your life is time it's one of
your greatest assets or it's your
liability
and being and i just turned 70 and i
have friends
who have nothing
i mean they have zero now they made
they've made
a lot of money
but they have nothing here
they have nice houses nice cars
16 wives 19 kids i don't know what they
have you know what i mean and and being
young is great except it can be a
liability to you
because when you're young you're just
having a lot of fun and life's exciting
you know it's new
so as a time but the thing is this is
the lesson today
is so many people spend their time
focusing
here
they want to make a lot of money
and i can hear it in their words they
say oh
i want a career
this is career
okay or
i'm going to start my own business
and
this is the chart here which we've seen
this is the cash flow quadrant book
number two e is employee
s is small business self-employed or a
specialist like a doctor a lawyer web
web designer
b is big business 500 employees or more
and i is professional investor
so
when i was your age i knew i wanted to
get here this takes time
this is the hardest you know
this is where the big mega bucks are and
kim and i are here
and the money is massive
but it takes time to get there
the big mistake i see young people make
as they focus here
and the words are i want to do
what i love
that's the track
you see in real life sometimes you have
to do what you hate
like people think i like to write books
i hate writing books
but it fills my purpose in life it's not
my passion my purpose in life
because my purpose was to get here
a lot of these guys get trapped here
doing what they love
as we've talked about on earlier
episodes of this thing you guys pay the
highest taxes 40 here
60 percent in taxes here
twenty percent here and then zero
percent here
so when i was in my before my twenties
i knew i wanted to go there
and it wasn't doing what i loved i had
to learn what i didn't want to learn
i had sometimes to do what i hated i had
to learn about taxes i had to learn
about debt i had to take classes i had
to learn about insurance
so i was doing a lot of things i hated
doing so i could come over here these
guys never do this because they live
their passion i want my passion
the difference in passion is greedy
purpose is for other people so my
purpose was to come over here so i could
serve more people
okay
so i have employees here and all this i
don't buy stocks bonds mutual funds
because as a professional investor i can
create my own assets there's three kinds
of money today that you guys got to be
aware of one is god's money and god's
money is gold and silver so this is
silver
and this is gold the reason i brought
this most people don't know what it
looks like
and then there's government money which
is fiat currency which is the dollar the
yen the peso the euro the yuan yeah
fake and everybody's working hard for it
it's like eating fake food or drinking
fake water that's why people are getting
sick financially because they're working
for fake money yeah okay
um then there's fake acids which with
another part of the fake millennial the
fake generation series
but the reason i brought this here is
most people haven't seen it
this here is real silver
plata
that's what it looks like and so in 1972
and this here is gold yeah
this is god's money this is what god's
money looks like
the reason i call it god's money is you
can't fake it
you know you can fake it with a fake etf
like a gold etf or a silver which i
don't touch because it smells as bad as
the guys that printed that crap
you know what i mean
jesus
but this is real money so
you look at this here
when i first started buying that that
was a dollar forty yeah
today that's sixteen dollars
and this here is auto gold
and the reason we brought it is most
people haven't seen or touch this is
real this is god's money why did i say
it's god's money because it was here
when the earth was created
and it'll be here when we're all dead
and gone when you're saving those fake
dollars
this will still be here yeah or those
fake etfs all those fake stocks you've
been making headlines everyone's
covering it where you're warning people
hey folks
brace for a major market crash here
right when you bring us this christmas
robert
well you know the reason i love you guys
is because we're i'm hardcore gold
silver and you know i'm bitcoin and all
this i'm a hard asset guy
so it's good news for us
but it's bad news uh for the boomers
very bad news
and um
what's happening is jay powell of the
fed is trying to push the yield curve up
but as most of you know the real yield
curve is a euro dollar curve
it's not the fed curve
and the euro dollar curve went inverted
every time that has happened
tragedy follows
so most of us are old enough to remember
the last time that yield curve and not
the last time but an earlier time was
the eurodollar euro curve and inverted
and the fed was trying to hold it up
so the fed's pushing it this way but the
euro dollar is going this way
and that led to the lehman moment 2008
so then what happened in uh 2019
it inverted again the repo market
inverted the euro dollar inverted and
covet appeared
so once again the euro dollar yield
curve inverted just recently
and i'm i'm standing alongside my friend
jim records
that this next one is going to be the
biggest of all
now
it's good news for some people but
horrible news for the boomers who are
starting to retire
so if you're a stock market person then
you're counting on the stock market to
keep you alive yeah you know let's say
let's say you're 65 years old and you're
gonna live to 85 you might be in serious
trouble when you were in school were you
an a student
or a c student
you know where you're the star of the
class or the flunky of the class
and if you weren't the a student then
did that mean you were you couldn't be
successful
does that is that what it means to you
if you didn't go to a great school
you're never going to be successful
what if you drop out you know what if
you drop out like steve jobs and uh bill
gates that means you've had it
jack ma who was the founder who was the
founder of a little company called
alibaba he just recently said
if you're 35 and you're not rich and
successful you'll never be successful
of course jack ma is a school teacher
former school teacher who struck it rich
but naturally
they have this idea
that if you're not successful in school
you'll never be successful in life
and my contention has always been it
almost damages you in school
you know school damaged my brain and my
father was the head of education for the
state of hawaii phd
and i hated school i mean i sat there
and getting pounded all the time for
being stupid a lot of your generation
are saying tax to rich
as they say never happened joe
because the tax laws need the rich
to do what the government wants done
their incentives i provide housing
jobs
and
food and energy
so that's what they should be teaching
but our schools will never teach that
because they're fake teachers
hey anything else so that's kind of a
review of rich dad poor dad yeah thank
god you gave that i mean even when you
said when you were talking about jobs
it's like well yeah none of us would be
here if it wasn't for you creating this
company yeah and so um
it's kind of curious as to why the
government wouldn't want us to be
creating more houses more more companies
why aren't they making us learn this in
school
well because it's fake education
it's fake teachers it's been going on
for hundreds of years and uh like i said
when the rich took over those
rockefellers carnegie mellon
and they said let's
you know said we don't need more
entrepreneurs
we need more employees
so the purpose of american education is
to create soldiers
and employees
people who just do us are tall but know
nothing about money who wants to live
below their means i want to live
the best life i can possibly live
so i talk about this often i use
liability if i want to buy a new ferrari
i first buy an asset and the asset pays
for the ferrari
i i wanted a rolls royce why because i
never had a rolls royce i've had
bentleys
so i built an asset and the asset then
bought my rolls royce now i'm kind of
bored with cars
so i don't have a guilty thing is that i
have financial education which is what
the rich dad company teaches and you can
have the same thing too
you just have to stop listening to those
school teachers who are poor you know
most school school teachers like my poor
dad very good good people but they're so
terrified of making mistakes
they want they want a steady paycheck
and they want a guaranteed pension
i don't think you can get rich from that
point of view look at this chart here
it's called the cash flow quadrant
e and s employee and self-employed that
was my poor debt you know they these
guys work for money
these guys are not capitalists they work
for money and they invest their own
money
on the b and the i side is my rich dad
site that's the capitalist site
capitalists use other people's labor and
other people's money to get rich which
side do you want to be on i'd rather be
on the capitalist side so that's the
only difference it's a whole shift of
mindset and education but everybody can
do it if you want to do it real estate
is a very important asset class so
a lot of people think well i have stocks
i have bonds at mutual funds but they're
just assets and but real estate is to me
the single most important asset class to
study especially today since i just was
watching cnbc in a bubble vision
and they finally acknowledge that zillow
has a 7 000 property problem because
they flip property and naturally i text
and i don't flip property i hold
property forever i collect rent forever
and i pay no taxes
so if you like paying taxes then you
know don't invest in real estate if you
like paying taxes have a 401k biggest
rip-off i've ever seen
but so that's why real estate has an
asset class in the macro picture
globally is the single
most important
subject but also the most complex and
the reason it's complex
is
you if you buy let's say apple stock
and you make a mistake you'll say you
buy apple at 10 where's what's a tesla a
thousand bucks or something
you buy tesla a thousand bucks and it
starts to crash you can get out tonight
you can get out immediately but you buy
a piece of real estate you can't get out
so in financial literacy which most
school teachers have no idea what that
means the word is called liquidity
and the reason real estate needs to be
studied more than any other subject
other than entrepreneurship
is liquidity you start a business you
can't get out you can make a mistake if
you buy a piece of real estate you can't
get out millennials are the most highly
emanated most highly educated
generation in history they have the cell
phone they didn't get educated in school
they got educated on social media
on their cell phones
they know all the answers
but they're afraid of doing anything
yeah you know the biggest complaint
about my generation
is millennials know all the answers but
they can't do anything
and the reason they can't do anything is
because you might hurt somebody's
feelings you might make a mistake
you know this just keeps you guys just
trapped in this little box here yeah
so that's one of the reasons i think
millennial money is such an important
point here
because if you're going to come into my
world old guys world or
the information age you've really got to
understand what is risky and what is not
risky and in my world if you play it
safe
that makes you stupid
because if you don't take risks you
don't get smarter yeah
you know so you may know the answer but
you can't do anything yeah and one of
the best things i had is i went from mel
i went to military school that i went to
flight school
i had such great teachers you know
all of them could fly you know so my
flight instructor could fly what a novel
idea
you know a flight instructor can fly
but when i was in high school
most of my teachers were
terrified
they're all cowards you know job
security don't make mistakes just
memorize the right answer and you'll be
safe
and that's why most school teachers
aren't rich yeah and they teach that to
your generation yeah most people are
afraid of debt
you ask you go home tonight and you say
well they talk to me about using debt
and most people go like this
because they don't teach you about money
see debt is money
after 1971 when nixon took the dollar
off the gold standard
money became debt
and so the people who are losers are
savers
so as kenny says you put your money in
the bank as a saver
kenny goes in and borrows it out as a
debtor and we use that money to buy
millions of dollars worth of real estate
so kenny just went over a billion
dollars worth of real estate using debt
but most people say well i can't i can't
do that because i don't have any money
you don't have any money because lesson
number one says
the rich don't work for money
so we learn to use debt to create assets
and assets keep putting money in our
pocket if you're going to be an
entrepreneur it's going to be the
biggest adventure of your life as long
as you want to keep learning
but if you just want to make a few bucks
you'll be taxed to death yeah that's the
s quadrant e s b i
that's the problem
and yes you know small business loans
are now they don't give me any money
it's hard to raise capital as an s sure
crowd funding all that stuff but i'd
rather go to wall street i'd rather
raise my own capital yeah but those are
skill sets
so i say to every entrepreneur look at
us the biggest education plan you'll
ever go through
you know i don't care about college
degree or not
but you better you better learn really
quickly fast have good people around you
and keep studying the irony of you know
when i when i left school in the 60s
there was plenty of jobs
but the world has changed
and our schools haven't
and so they're still making this innate
promise of get a job
and i was very fortunate when i
graduated in 69 we're the highest paid
graduates in the world my classmates
were making about 120 150 000 a year
there's not much money today
but
1969 that was a lot of money
but naturally as young guys do we spent
every penny of it
so i had my rich dad's lesson the rich
don't work for money in my head i said
okay
i'm making all this money i have a
secure job
but what's beyond that and that's where
education comes in
so if i could explain this to you for
the for the rest of the millennial
lessons it's really going to be on this
theme here
because financial education is about not
working for money
like one of the first questions when i
finally realized what my rich dad was
saying i said well when do i never need
a paycheck again
see my goal wasn't you know
go to the moon or
you know cure cancer my job was
when
would i never need a paycheck again
because as long as you need a paycheck
be it from an employer or like my poor
dad
he was so afraid of losing his
government pension yeah
i'm going jesus what a way to run your
life your pension
so my old man kind of kind of got fired
he lost his pension
it was the most frightening thing in the
world to him he had no pension then it
was social security which is even worse
so that's why my goal when i was about
your age a little older around 25 i said
my goal is to never need a paycheck
again from anybody
even the government i don't want any
medicare social security
or whatever you know i was a military
pilot so you got to get the military
pilot pension i said you do but i'm not
going to
and just because of this here that was
the difference because i never wanted to
work for money to need a paycheck
so the next few lessons and millennial
money you'll find out what i do work for
so for right now just let me go to the
lesson here
so this comes from rich dad poor dad and
this these are some of the distinctions
it was the advantage i had at age nine
because i knew
what i wanted to work for
and this here in simple terms is called
a financial statement
in school the teacher get a fico score
fico is bs all that means how good are
you paying your bills that's all fico
means okay should be the fido score good
dog
so this is what your banker wants to see
so when i was
nine years old playing monopoly with my
rich dad this is the lesson that's not
included in monopoly but rich dad taught
me
and
fundamentally
the problem
that most people make they go to school
to get a job
and they work here so this is the poor
middle class in these guys
and we're going to talk about later your
first line out of expense is taxes
you know just recently president trump
said he had a tax cut
he didn't have a tax cut for these guys
as you know the rules are always written
for the rich okay i didn't make the
rules you can get angry at me but these
are the rules the rich make the rules
the golden rule who he who has a gold
makes the rules
yeah so the tax cut went to people here
that's where it goes you'll learn more
about this later on
but this is what i work for
so what i work for number one is
i'm an entrepreneur i want businesses i
have multiple businesses
and i don't work in them as you know
because you work here you never see me
do it no
because i don't work for a paycheck
next is real estate
and real estate is good
for many things which we'll go into but
number one is debt i use a lot of debt
to buy real estate and i pay no taxes
that's the relationship there
the next is paper
and that's saving stocks bonds mutual
funds etfs and that stuff i don't have
any of that stuff i don't save money i
don't any of that but this is why most
people have a go to school get a job
get a 401k and save money
loser
i'm doing that just to upset you guys
because maybe you'll start to think
because i didn't make the rules i'm just
telling these are the rules
these people pay the highest taxes
and they work the hardest
and the last are commodities
four different asset classes so
commodities are
number one is gold silver oil
land water food
so this is what i work for when i left
school rather than working for a
paycheck
and working for money
my education had to go beyond getting a
job which i had a good job
but i now had to start when i left
school about your age
the thing i focused on first actually
was commodities
so back in 1972 i started buying gold
and it was illegal for americans to own
gold you can imagine that
back in 72.
today you have bitcoin it's different
okay everything is changing so rapidly
today
so i started with gold
but actually the next thing was actually
oil because i went to school to be a
tanker officer driving ships for
standard oil
so understand oils i own my wife and i
don't own standard oil or chevron or
exxon we own oil wells again
taxes you get no tax breaks for owning
paper oil
huge tax breaks for owning real oil
and then i went into real estate
why because i can use debt to buy real
estate and because i use debt
i pay no taxes
and then third i started my business my
first real real business had many many
businesses as a kid
but my first real business was a nylon
and velcro surface wallet business
and i went worldwide right away the
trouble is i was an idiot
and the business went up
and the business came down
what kept me alive was this and this
okay so you may say well aren't you
working for money but we'll go into that
next i don't want what's called
a paycheck
i want cash flow
from here
so that's what i mean by the rich don't
work for money
you want cash flow that pays very little
taxes
and i can use lots of debt over here the
average person went to school
their biggest liability they have is
student loans of course
yeah of course definitely
i mean it's horrible what they do to you
guys today
yeah student loan was just the worst
type of debt of all because you cannot
declare bankruptcy on it
then you get out you try and buy a house
and you call it an asset when it's
really a liability
why because the cash is flowing that way
your house costs you money every you
rent a house still cost you money
okay
then you have to have a nice car
i had one of those
so the problem with most young people is
they go to school to get that job
then a lot of them have student loan
debt
then they try and get married and buy a
house they have a car
and then they have credit card debt
but they never have the chance to come
over here if they do any investing in
america it's a 401k
which i wouldn't touch with a 10-foot
pole now you should but i don't because
i don't have to
because i went to school for here
and people who don't go to school should
be here this is a 401k ira etfs and that
stuff paper
savings i don't touch that stuff and
we'll go into that later on okay
so when i say rich don't work for money
i never want to be dependent on a
paycheck either from an employer
or the government i want to be a free
human being did you ever wonder how the
rich don't pay taxes of course i mean it
went viral when trump said he's paid
zero in taxes and so it got me wondering
too it's like well one how can i do that
because i need that i mean it would be
great if i could pay zero in taxes and
two
how exactly
can they structure it to get zero in
taxes it goes over here to um
fake money fake teachers fake assets
it's all the same and all of these guys
who are screaming for the rich not to
pay taxes
i cover it in fake
i actually have an article from the new
york times
where they interviewed jared kushner who
was trump's son-in-law you know
was ivanka's husband yeah
they're
they're richer than the trumps
jared kushner's family the richer than
the trumps
but the reason jared explains it
why these guys pay no tax
is because they're in real estate
they're not in stock spots mutual funds
and etfs
and so he explains it so the reason the
rich don't pay taxes
is because there's three types of income
they'll never teach you this in school
the fake teachers and everything
number one type of there's three types
of income
okay number one type of income is earned
income
that's earned income
it's when you work for money
it's earned so that earned income
shows up here
so these are the guys that pay tax so
when all the guys are screaming taxed
are rich
well you can't tax them because they
don't have jobs
it's kind of funny isn't it you're going
to tax the rich oh yeah good luck
and the second type of income
is portfolio income and portfolio income
is from flipping houses or you buy a
stock for like ten dollars you sell it
for twenty dollars
that's portfolio income okay i don't do
that trump doesn't do that
so most guys who are flipping houses and
all that buying stocks and flipping two
foot two
you're getting this type of income so
this
this income is about 20 today
some of that here
but the income that the rich work for
is called
passive income
passive income is also known as cash
flow
that's the name of our game
cash flow
and that income is income
that's flowing from here to here it
bypasses taxes
so i know this doesn't sound fair and it
isn't fair i don't disagree with you but
what's not fair is our schools which are
part of the problem we'll never explain
that
and so because it's passive income is it
not taxed
because i guess you guys are creating
jobs and
owning and providing houses
you're getting smarter there
it's not illegal because the tax laws
are incentives to do what the government
wants done so the reason
the trumps kill sockets and kushners pay
no taxes is we provide housing
number two in the b column we provide
jobs so we pay no taxes
and three you know it's a bad word is
oil when you droll for oil you pay no
taxes
but if you buy chevron you pay taxes
stocks
if you provide food you pay no taxes
so
if real financial education which will
never be taught in school
because they're fake teachers how do you
deal with critics like do you have a
go-to formula like how do you deal with
that
again rich i thank you for that you and
rolo i'm not i am not
because i don't i don't like i don't i
don't need to do this
is when you talk about chasing
excellence and getting people into frame
you know and one of the things i used to
do is i'd shine off people they come up
and talk to me about well thank you for
another book
and now i don't do that so people stop
me and say thank you for writing a book
i stay with them
i am
my excellence is to be a better human
being with them everybody that comes up
to me
because nothing was going to my head
because i'm busy
and i don't have time for somebody to
tell me how they made 10 000 bucks and i
just go
whoa you know
i sit there listen to them but you know
but it's in everything i do can i be
excellent at it
can i be better human being towards them
and it's in what that's that's what i'm
saying it's
it's the word excellence is a mental
word
but how do i convert it to action
and when i convert it to action i change
you know my uh maria montessori the
montessori school system she says what
the hand does the mind remembers
but too many academics they have good
memory but they can't do [__]
you know i mean that's my whole family
the great people phds i have one distant
relative
he's 40 years old he's living in the
basement he's going for a section second
phd
i can't find a job i said yeah
is god trying to tell you something
yes just don't pay attention to that so
what do you do you don't have any time
to pay attention to haters if you're
chasing excellence right
well
there's a there's a saying i have you
know don't teach pigs to sing
it waste your time it annoys the pig
so i don't argue with them i'm a writer
but i wouldn't be here if i didn't take
the hard route and the reason i couldn't
write was because i was a surfer
now i love surfing and i had dreams of
someday becoming a professional surfer
and then i kind of it dawned on me
that i was
my cr my friends
were cool guys you know they're good
looking they're great bodies and they're
all cool and drinking and smoking and
having a good time i didn't do any of
that stuff
but they lack discipline that was the
thing i said you know they have no
discipline they're cutting class or
doing this and where am i going to wind
up if i follow them so i kind of woke up
and
i realized i needed discipline
now discipline is not
punishment because there is punishment
you see if you're not disciplined the
world will punish you
but also you will punish yourself
so i kind of realized that and that's
why i applied for military school nobody
thought i could get in because my grades
were
d's and f's
but i had high sat scores
and so i went to a military school in
new york
and i have found discipline and then i
joined the marine corps for more
discipline and then i became a pilot in
vietnam for more discipline so when i
meet most people today and i'm the same
way we all want the easy road give me
the easy answer think about
entrepreneurs you're not you're not
manual labor
so you're working with your mind your
body your spirit and your emotions you
know you just sure timing things
observing things you have to have good
friends people you trust implicitly yeah
and like i have fantastic staff you know
i trust them with you know some of my
people have been around me for 20 years
my some of my best partners are 40 years
and we know we trust each other so that
takes time when i was nine years old my
rich dad taught me how to become rich by
playing the game of monopoly and i
didn't understand why i was playing this
game on monopoly and one day rich dad
said to me says there's many ways you
can become rich
one of the best ones i found this game
monopoly because games are some of the
best teachers in the world because all
games engage four intelligences number
one is your mind
number two are your emotions you know
fear and anger and sadness
number three
is physical i mean how can you learn to
walk if you don't fall down and number
four is spiritual intelligence
as maria montessori said what the hand
does
the mind remembers as my teacher was dr
r buckminster fuller
and he says i don't work for me i work
for everyone
and that was one of the biggest lessons
i got from the military you know from
the military was very high spiritual
intelligence that's why your dad and i
get along so well
because when we went into combat which
is a horrible experience of good and bad
people enemy and friends you know
but we when we climbed into our aircraft
there was a crew of five
we became one
it is the best feeling as horrible as it
is
flying into combat
because we might not come back
but it was the highest feeling of all
it was spiritual
and i'm afraid it's not just millennials
as human beings you know
well you know is this good is this bad
is this the best
viton shirt can i get at a better price
or he's cute or she's cute you know i
mean but is there somebody better
right yeah i mean that's exactly what's
going on so you guys are stuck in your
head
and i think it should get more into your
spirit you know like saying
what can i do for my fellow human being
yeah what can i do for the environment
and i think the biggest secret of my
success is i i have all you know we all
have these
we all have some degree of physical
things we do
emotionally i'm a i'm a basket case a
lot of the time you know
i get upset i get angry i get sad i get
my feelings hurt
and i'm always this is good this is bad
this is you know you watch politics it's
all good and bad it's a bunch of
but what keeps me going is this
and it's spiritual yeah it's how can i
serve
others how can i serve the planet in my
world i said
i see people they chase shiny objects
and
what a shiny object means is you know
when you're fishing you throw a lure out
of those little shiny obstacles and the
fish comes and
when they jump in
that's what most people do
bitcoin today is a shiny object i'm not
saying you can't make a lot of money in
it
but most people are chasing shiny
objects they want to make money
they're not building an asset here
the thing the reason they don't do it
here
this is the highest risk
now
this is what i know the higher the risk
the more education it takes
for example
if i wanted to learn and i flew if i
wanted to just fly my little cessna 172
around the place not much risk in that
but when i had to go to vietnam to fly
the risk went up i had to study harder
become better work harder at it
the reason most people stay in paper
401ks iras and chasing shiny objects
like bitcoin
is because
they don't want to take the risk here
they're huge
you've got to study that's where rich
dad's education rich dad's coaching all
of you guys are allowed to take courses
and all this
if you come here it takes no
intelligence to be here
it takes no intelligence to buy bitcoin
i mean i have four
four bitcoin no five bitcoin
i didn't take you know i just i don't
have to do anything
over here i have to do all i have to
know a lot over here i have to know a
lot
i have to study
so if you want a shiny object like the
stock market and all that you can make
get rich there
it's really easy to get in here it's
really hard here
any comments any questions does it make
sense they're chasing shiny objects so i
do agree with you when you talk about
bitcoin being a shiny object that
everybody's chasing right
and one of my favorite stories that
you've told is about your mentor frank
when he sent you to peru so you could
learn a valuable lesson about maybe
something that wasn't such a shiny
object and turned in to be because shiny
objects change every day
so i wanted to learn about i didn't have
icos
initial coin offerings i wanted to learn
about ipos initial public offering and
it's how you take a business and turn it
into paper
you turn it into stock
so i went to see my friend frank who was
hardcore here how many companies he
started taking public
and i said frank and he didn't know me
from adam i said i want to learn to do
an ipo he goes yeah you and everybody
else he said most guys don't have it
they don't have the guts they don't have
the determination and they're wimps
i said i want to learn says how bad
this is up here in scottsdale arizona
i said badly he says okay this is
wednesday
be in lima peru
on saturday i went
on saturday
and we were shooting the our video for
the cash flow game you know
he says how bad do you want it
i said badly
he says i'll you know you meet my
president in lima frank never traveled
you meet my president in lima and i'll
find out how bad you want it
so that was wednesday wednesday night i
was on a plane to lima peru i had to pay
full boat i paid my own way most
employees can't stand that because they
don't have any money
i flew into lima peru i went to look at
three gold mines
and with frank's president
it was an experience and an education
i've never had i would never have i
didn't showed up
it cost me probably 15 to 20 000 just
for airfare on that thing i get back on
tuesday to talk to frank and i said
frank there's nothing there he says i
could have told you that
so why'd you send me
i want to find how badly you want to
learn
says most people don't have it
they want a job they want job security
they want a paycheck they want a 401k
and that's why they don't get to come
here that's why they don't get to come
over here nothing right or wrong you
know
i don't ever want to be here i knew when
i was your age i want to come here but
the higher the risk
the higher the returns
but also the higher dedication education
and study you have to go through so
today
and i'm making millions and millions i
make more
in a day than most many people make in a
lifetime
but it was worth it
did i lose sometimes yes but it was
worth it
you go to school here you take no risk
that's why my poor dad was poor he
didn't like to make mistakes the
difference differences between
what they're teaching in school and what
we at rich dad teach so this this is the
very big difference like i said most
school teachers
are like my poor dad
and
this was actually this was rich dad
puerto what you're seeing here is a
financial statement
you know rich dad poor dad has a book on
accounting the most boring subject on
planet earth
but book number two of rich dad was this
one here
and this was called the cash flow
quadrant right you have e
s
b
and i so test for you what does eu stand
for employee good and what the employees
always say
that they work for money
but they want job security exactly
paycheck and pension yes okay what does
s stand for self-employed a small
business owners yes
doctors lawyers they work for tips they
work for tips
so they're self-employed and b stands
for what big business owners so 500
employees or more yeah and i stands for
the investor investor it's more than
just investor it's insider
you see this is like shark tank on the
tv shows
these guys here have done this and
they've done this
so this was my poor dad
this site this was rich dad here
so the difference that's what schools
are not teaching you is what's the
difference between these people
and these people
that's the big difference and that shows
up so
when i was about your age i had to make
a decision did i want to i was a pilot
you know my most my friends went to fly
for the airlines
but i'd be here
or i could be a
you know i could have a little i could
be in alaska flying fishermen around the
place you know a private a pilot with a
small plane and you know flying around
the place
or i could own an airlines
or i could invest in airlines and that's
the difference in the mindsets and skill
sets
you don't just make crossings the
education is extremely different on this
side than on this side here i would say
the most important thing at this
juncture in history in 2022 let's get
smarter
listen to real teachers
you know that was the choice i had to
make at the age of nine don't listen to
my poor dad was a phd
or to listen to my rich dad
that's a tough decision for a
nine-year-old kid
but when my when i came back from
vietnam i flew for the marine corps
my my poor dad said to go back to school
get my phd
and i said i can't do that and i became
an entrepreneur instead so i never i
never needed a job again
that was the difference i was a free
human being i'm sitting in sunday school
at seven and the sunday school teacher
says hey why were the three wise men
wise
and i said because they were rich
she said why why do you think the wise
men are rich and say well they had gold
frankincense and myrrh
she says that's not the reason they were
rich i said what's the reason
and it was i never forgot her reason she
says they always sought the best teacher
and they're not religious but they were
seeking jesus christ
so
in times of trouble always seek the best
teachers let me draw this prayer you
guys have seen it before
but
again if you look at it this way this is
intelligences
and this is what makes us up this makes
us human beings we have mental
intelligence
we have
physical intelligence
you know like tiger woods is a fantastic
golfer i suck you know
and then you have
emotional intelligence and emotional
intelligence
they call it eq is the most important
because i get my feelings hurt all the
time i get angry i you know i i
hallucinate in my head you know i think
things that aren't true but the biggest
one of all is the spiritual
and where
difference between mental
and spiritual
it's very simple
mental causes too
so
man woman
good bad up down
where spiritual is one so let me give
you an example
why do i do my work
yesterday i was driving down the road
and i saw this young guy god
just broke my heart you know he's
standing there in hot phoenix sun
he says unemployed
need money to feed the kids and all that
now mentally i could say well get a job
you idiot
but spiritually i i
am him
i feel for him
so in my work
i work for this
you know like i don't need the money
yeah
but i as my teacher was dr r buckminster
fuller
and he says i don't work for me i work
for everyone
and that was one of the biggest lessons
i got from the military you know from
the military was very high spiritual
intelligence that's why your dad and i
get along so well
because when we went into combat which
is a horrible experience of good and bad
people
enemy and friends you know
but we when we climbed into our aircraft
there was a crew of five
we became one
it is the best feeling as horrible as it
is
flying into combat
because we might not come back but it
was the highest feeling of all
it was spiritual
and i'm afraid it's not just millennials
as human beings you know
well you know is this good is this bad
is this the best
viton shirt can i get at a better price
or he's cute or she's cute you know i
mean but is there somebody better
right yeah i mean that's exactly what's
going on
you guys are stuck in your head
and i think you should get more into
your spirit you know like saying
what can i do for my fellow human being
yeah what can i do for the environment
and i think the biggest secret of my
success is i i have all you know we all
had these
we all have some degree of physical we
things we do
emotionally i'm a i'm a basket case a
lot of the time you know
i get upset i get angry i get sad i get
my feelings hurt
and i'm always this is good this is bad
this is you know you watch politics it's
all good and bad there's a bunch of
but what keeps me going is this
and it's spiritual yeah it's how can i
serve
others how can i serve the planet how
can i fix this problem get to the point
where you don't need money it's called
the infinite return
and that's my my next book coming out
next year yeah when you get to the point
where you don't need money
you're home free
you'll never need money you don't care
you could always put a deal together you
can always create an asset out of
nothing you know it's like
i don't know what else it's the power of
god-given power
so like i said when i write a book i'm
selling 50 copies 50 licenses day one
and let's say i get 10 000 a license how
much is that 50 times 10 000. is it 500
000.
50 times 10 000. yeah that's a hundred
thousand yeah so i'm in i'm in the black
immediately what does it cost me maybe
ten thousand to write a book
do you know so i'm in the black
the same thing if i trade a stock i'll
buy a stock a dollar it goes up to 10
and i sell
so i have all free trading stock i have
no money in it that's what buffett's
doing they're all infinite return guys
sure
you have no money into the deal and you
can do it with anything and the paycheck
is one of the most sinister plots ever
pulled upon a human being
if you need a paycheck you've sold your
soul
you know you've sold your body your mind
your spirit and your emotions you sit
there in fear of losing your job or can
i get a raise or you know will i get
promoted
i mean and then and then
why would you do that and the other
thing about reason we endorse network
marketing we don't think of it as a
network marketing we think of it as
entrepreneur development because if you
need a paycheck this is not your
business
you know we build businesses
so sometimes when kim and i do a deal we
may not receive a paycheck for five six
years
you know and so these guys come
am i going to get rich quick
you know and some people do i don't know
you do or not but that is an employee
get rich loser mindset and so the thing
that network marketing does is really
kind of cure you
of that loser paycheck get rich quick
mentality and actually build a business
you know we build businesses
but and that's how we're rich but we
didn't get rich quick and i don't need a
paycheck and i never want a paycheck so
that's kind of a revolutionary thought
to most people up there who went to
school
to get good grades and get a job you
know they get a high pay job and then
the higher paying job you you pay higher
taxes and you wonder why you never get
ahead that's because you went to school
to get a job and a paycheck you've got
to get away from the paycheck and
sometimes it might take two three years
to get away from that and that's what
network marketing teaches people it's an
entrepreneur's mindset it's an
entrepreneur's spirit not a loser
employee i need a paycheck mentality
what are you doing to make your money so
if i was
selling drugs
that you know that would that be a
violation of my my morals and my ethics
and um
and then what do you do with your money
so you know when i was first starting
off in real estate
i had to learn and i had to learn how to
inspect the property
so there's a there's all different
classes of real estate
so i started off in what they call
trailers you know those little mobile
they just tow them up there
i'm going in there
and i go
here's this crappy ass trailer they're
renting from this guy but the guy's got
a brand new ford pickup outside
you know i'm going i don't have a brand
new ford pickup
but you can always you can always learn
the reason the guy's poor
instead of owning his poor he could be
doing the same thing i'm doing
but the reason he's poor he's always
trading in his new his pickup because
they'll give him you know we'll give you
extra money for everything just sign
here and all this they just keep getting
into debt
and that's why i wrote rich dad poor dad
and i've created my cash flow board game
and all this
because man we don't teach people
between assets and liabilities and
income expenses and cash flow
we're poor anyway
it doesn't make a difference how much
you make because i have a lot of friends
who are look rich you know what i mean
they got the mercedes got the roller got
the big house but this coved has blown
them apart they don't have no foundation
they look good
you know they dress nice
they wear the nice watches and the
clothes
but they're now having to sell their
properties because they can't afford it
you know i'm talking about it's the same
problem
you know
it's just how you manage your money this
is gold this is real security it's god's
money so is silver and so is bitcoin due
to the blockchain technology
i'm not saying buy any of this stuff i'm
just telling you why i own this
so this is real money i mean i can
travel anywhere in the world as value
goes up and down as just manipulated and
i can spend it
but what this is the zimbabwe dollar is
fake money and the only way this comes
into existence
is an entrepreneur like me creates an
asset you know a rich dad court has
about assets versus liabilities
so i go into
blackrock and i say guess what i have a
startup here you know i mean tesla or
something
and tesla's now a trillion dollar
company
but what happens if gm and you know
biden doesn't like tesla i can tell but
he doesn't he doesn't recommend him i'm
not in the game
i'm not in that dog fight
but let's say that gm comes out with an
electric car that you can buy for two
bucks
tesla's toast
do what i mean yeah but so much of the
stock market is based upon the event the
valuation of a company like tesla
or like the earlier thing you know
netflix or blockbuster video
so much of it you don't know what's
called the counterparty to it
the only counterparty to this is god
god made this and silver god made this
and um
the bitcoin is blockchain
that's because you know ethereum and
blockchain
so some people ask me i'm satoshi's and
i don't speak japanese but
i i don't know anything about blockchain
but i just don't trust this
i don't trust the us dollar i don't
trust the fed i don't trust the treasury
and i don't trust our government and i
don't trust wall street
if you do
invest your [__] but what they're
doing is they're creating what i call a
fake asset
yeah so let's say i go there and say you
know sarah i'm starting this company
and i've been there they hyped the
company oh this is
yeah and so really the issue is trust
today this thing here is in god we trust
there's no counterparty risk to it but
there's a lot of counterparty risk to
this and there's a lot of counterparty
risk to blackrock to the stock market
and all this but right now if you're in
minneapolis and they vote to defund the
police you're toast
i mean your
your your hundred thousand dollar house
goes to ten thousand bucks because
nobody wants to live there
so you understand it's not real estate
is really the macro around real estate
and i i've never met so many idiots in
my life you know i'm going holy mackerel
and just remember this you know you can
buy a stock like amazon and you make a
mistake you can get out tonight
you buy a piece of real estate like in
minneapolis wherever they're going to
defund the police you can't get out
you're going to ride that titanic down
you know kim and i had to sell a piece
of property in portland oregon
beautiful property there all the bells
and whistles on the water you know both
docks all this crap
but the trouble is that tenants couldn't
get in there because the number of
homeless camped out in front of it were
thick the tenants couldn't get to the
property and the police wouldn't do
anything so real quickly this is a cash
flow quadrant you know you have a stands
for employee s sensible self-employed or
small business or a specialist like a
doctor or a lawyer
b stands for big business 500 employees
or more
and i stands for insider investor
see these guys are passive investors
they're outsiders
these guys invest from the inside so the
eyes are like shark tank guys like mark
cuban and all that they're they're
entrepreneurs
who now acquire other companies
so when i was
probably in my 20s
or when i was growing up should i say my
my my dad wanted me to be an employee so
when i got out of the marine corps i
could fly so they want me to fly for the
airlines as a pilot i said i didn't want
to do that
and my mom she wanted she was a nurse
and she wanted me to be a specialist
like a medical doctor
and i said to my mom it says one problem
said
medical doctors are smart that's what s
stands for she goes you're right you'll
never be a doctor
so i only had
one hope was to go to the b side
and the eyesight
so
today
you know i own many many businesses and
i invest from the inside now some people
say well insider trading that's illegal
it's not illegal
there are certain parts of insider
trading that still illegal but the
biggest deal is always insight
so what my rich dad taught me says if
you're not on the inside you're on the
outside
and the reason most people don't make
much money is on the outside you know
just now uber and lyft floated on this
on the stock exchanges the insiders
already made their money
now the outsiders come in
that's the game
so i've taken in my lifetime i've taken
three companies public you know
on the toronto stock exchange a gold
company a silver company and an oil
company
i did it because i wanted to find out
what it's like to be on this side on the
b and the i side
and they're completely different worlds
different mindsets different human
beings
so if you want to go to school this is
where people wind up ens
and rich dad stands for people who want
to be on this side here
it's it's a very different mindset skill
sets education processes this here the
reason
there's no counterparty risk this is an
element i forgot i forgot the sort
number silver is an element
and bitcoin is blockchain
there's no counterparty risk the this is
a zim dollar is no difference in the us
dollar or u.s stock or u.s bond
and so that's why you don't find me
saving dollars i save gold silver
bitcoin
and it could change you know i mean
bitcoin could become obsolete also but
the reason i listen to guys like anthony
pompliano and all the smart young guys
is they'll give me an early warning if
something's going to come up so you got
to pay attention to what youtube is
saying if they don't take them down that
they took gammon george gammon down
but ladies and gentlemen you've really
got to be smarter today and that's where
the rich dead company was founded we
don't sell
stocks or bonds or mutual funds or gold
you know we just sell awareness be aware
of what's happening if you want to speak
macro economics you always ask who's the
counterparty
so in other words if
when i borrowed money when i first
started out nobody would lend me money
because they don't trust me
you know because who are you yeah as a
villager got up and i lost a lot of
money at the start you know kim and i
got one broke and all this stuff
but each mistake we made we got smarter
we met smarter team members like our our
rich dad team right now we've been a lot
of crooks like our first ceo our second
cl our third ceo we've met
they're all crooks they cheat they lie
they steal
i can't believe it so kim and i were in
horrible shape because
you know the first people were oh we
love rich dad and they were
stealing as much as they could
holly mackerel but that's how you meet
you know the lesson we teach is that
every time you meet a bad partner you
made a good partner so most of our best
partners today came from bad partners
so you've got to be very very careful
because my new book's coming out it's
called the capitalist manifesto but the
terminology is this who is the
counterparty to this gold coin
god
and who is the counterparty to this the
government
who do you trust who's a counterparty to
bitcoin
blockchain
it's people's money
i trust the people more than the
government
and that's why uh i support bitcoin
could i be wrong possibly you know but
that's why i listen to youtube even
though they take me down all the time
but some of these guys like like i said
uh michael saylor and uh
pompliano and all this
they they'll send out the warning if
something's wrong like i said then kenny
and i were in dallas tech texas
at the sovereign man
and uh
arabic is up there you know the kenny
stands up and says i just borrowed 300
million dollars
the average guy can't get a 30 000 loan
much a 300 million dollar loan
but the power of real estate is debt and
the more debt you have you don't pay any
taxes but you better know what you're
doing because you don't just buy it for
that reason i was talking to john about
the party i went to these people were
talking about real estate
and i just had to tell us i i really
cannot endorse what you're doing
you're buying real estate at the top of
a market yes but real estate always goes
up i said maybe
maybe but if it comes down the trouble
of real estate is is illiquid
this gold here is as liquid as they come
i can go anywhere in the world
and somebody will give me money for it
anywhere
but real estate no
s p 500 is liquid this is liquid
and so is cash liquidism i've been
accused of being a racist so many times
i know and then i was accused of being a
white supremacist
looked in the mirror and said no i'm
still asian right
yeah i took you know three companies
public through toronto i mean first with
vc
vancouver stock exchange and i thought i
might migrate to the toronto stock
exchange why did i do that to learn
learn to help how to raise capital on
public markets
now the average entrepreneur never does
that you know they keep open their pizza
shop and they open two pieces of shops
that's that's about it because they're
into just for the money
i wanted to learn something so i i took
my first um
first was an oil company in portugal
and i took that public and everybody
told me there's no oil in portugal and i
found out the hard way they're right
there's no oil there
that company crashed and burned like a
airplane coming out of the sky you know
and then the next thing i started a
silver company in argentina and we
struck silver and we did very well yeah
and then i started a gold company in
china and the chinese took it
so uh
those are priceless experience
yeah aren't you bitter i go
yeah but
that's what i did it for you understand
that i did it for that so the tax
department which every country has taxes
determined they want to know what kind
of income do you work for
so when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent parent to the child
they say go to school get a job they're
working for this type of income
earned income
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here
and the first thing you pay is the
highest taxes
because you worked for money
yes the government doesn't want you
working for money they punish you for
that they want you to hire employees
or invest
okay so earned income is what they work
for the second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if i buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand i sell it
for two hundred thousand a hundred
thousand is capital gains if i buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest text
so the tax breaks that president trump
is working on today is primarily for
these guys here
so there are doctors lawyers
highly educated people
and they have stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff of
flipping houses you get a break
but what the really rich work for
is
passive income
and passive income
[Applause]
for me
i have a business
whether i work or not money comes in
and you've seen me i'm not here am i no
never
never i've heard my right not to be here
real estate i get milli
every year my wife and i can we add more
real estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still get this
but this is another type of
income
this here i'll
get into is called phantom income
it's taxes i don't pay so it's a little
bit beyond most people's minds
but let's say my tax bill is a hundred
thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break that means
fifty thousand in taxes i don't have to
pay
[Music]
so the fifty thousand dollars didn't go
to the government
it went back up here
so that's what financial education does
it teaches you
about the financial statement which is
not taught in school again they teach
you fico scores which is really fido
scores
what's your total little dougie
okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching you to work for now
ironically
when you save money and you have a 401k
this is the kind of income so savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better is the saving money in
what you call that 401ks is good
in canada it's called rrsp in australia
called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive and it's because
i'm an active investor i don't buy this
because this is passive investors
i am active i'm professional in all of
these areas
so i work for passive income which means
i'm not here
the check comes in the checks come in
every year and you've seen kim and i
and your mother now
she's working on here
and so your mother's income keeps going
up your father's income keeps going up
and they don't have a job what should
you do are you saying get out of
equities get out of your positions stay
in cash and keep that cash on the
sideline to take advantage
of the crash what are you
saying that
an investor who's watching kitko who's
watching these other channels who's
watching your channel should potentially
do in order to best protect their
portfolio well that's a great question
because the only reason you'd be worried
it really goes back to what was what did
you buy
yeah remember your profit is made when
you buy not when you sell
so i remember in 2000 gold went down to
like 300 or something like this i
thought i died and went to heaven
i just backed up the truck so when
bitcoin went to let's say twenty
thousand i was going well that's kind of
interesting i wanted back down to three
then rebounded to six
i picked it up at six and it's 41 today
so your profits are made when you buy
not when you sell so if you're worried
about your position you probably bought
too high so it's a lot so i said this
whole thing should you be an
entrepreneur well a lot has to do with
what your family said about it
you know my portal so the rich were
crooks
entrepreneurs were crooks
the rich were greedy
school all you had to do was have a
college degree you reset
different cultures yeah i had to go
against all this especially respecting
the father you've long advocated for
investing in real estate
as a source of income one of the biggest
premises of rich dad poor dad do you
still suggest investing in real estate
in the real estate market now
absolutely you want to invest in things
that last that's gem records invest in
what lasts but this is the key let me
explain behind me is my cash flow board
game
there's two tracks on the board game
there's a rat race which is a 401k guy
and then there's a fast track that's a
capitalist right in other words this is
it here
okay so this is my little this is book
two the rich dad series esbi
so our schools teach us to be employees
and self-employed like doctors lawyers
and stuff like this
capitalists teach people to be business
owners or brand owners
and investors
but the only way you get out of the rat
race is via a thing called a financial
statement so if you're at rich dad poor
dad
and if you're at cash flow quadrant and
you play the cash flow game
you have to have a financial statement
your financial statement is what your
banker wants to see so when i go talk i
just borrowed 31 million dollars a
couple of weeks ago
for a piece of property in austin texas
if i didn't have a strong financial
statement i couldn't borrow 31 million
dollars
and so what's happening today is the
poor middle class who went to school
they got their jobs and all this stuff
they're being wiped out while the rich
are getting richer because everything
the fed prints
stays in the asset class
not the business class so he's so
finally one day i had this
transformational event i did a thing
called test est heart seminars training
everybody did it you know this
and i sat in this room and i realized i
was a liar
and i realized that's well i'd never be
successful
because i could lie cheat and steal and
i was very good at it
and so i called up captain abrams and i
was living in hawaii in waikiki
i was making a lot of money in real
estate
and i called captain abrams and i said
captain i'm coming in
what do you mean you're coming in i said
i'm going to come in i will
tell you what i know.
you couldn't believe it you know i just
realized if i didn't confess my sins
that the catholic would say
i'd go to hell you know hell was not in
hell hell is i live with my lying
cheating stealing
every day of my life
so i took the stand and he deposed me i
told him the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
i told them every criminal event i
thought they weren't really criminal
they were petty thieves
i did stupid things like fly this did
this you know
i machine gun
goats from my helicopter
and as i did all this
at the end about three and a half hours
i think i lost 20 pounds
and he said i said to him since captain
because i'm going to go to jail
he says no just thank you for telling
the truth
gave me an honorable discharge
and it was one of the most profound
transformational
you know metamorphosis you go from an
immature form to an adult form i grew up
i said holy mackerel the truth will set
you free
i understand that at a level that the
average person will never know because i
had been such a scumbag
dishonest
disciplinary problem
and then you know like with my wife i've
never cheated on her most of my friends
cheat on their lives 70 percent do
but when i said i'd get married this
time
i would not cheat on her
marriage is still hard
but um cheating makes it worse if you
know what i mean so it's a matter of not
trying to change the world out there
you know the crisis is between this here
and this year and in your heart
and yes being a military leader a
wartime leader is important because it
takes about it's about courage at this
time
it's about being true for being
forthright being upright being a
stand-up guy
that's the difference today
and it's not about what the crooks are
doing is what you're doing it was really
hard because i didn't like
i'm actually a very shy person
so learning how to sell was the hardest
thing i could do
but if i hadn't spent four years
learning how to sell i never made it
here i never made it here
so the entire time that you were here
you were preparing to jump to the other
questions correct
so every job is not so much for the
high-paying job of job security
for not not everybody most people should
have job security because
they're not designed to be entrepreneurs
but if you're going to be an
entrepreneur then you better take this
job and say well which way am i going to
go yeah
so i knew my job at xerox
was to go here and here and here yeah
not stay here
and i actually make so much money over
here that i don't need job security
money
so really that's the lesson when you
look at a job you look at what can i
learn
more than how much can i make
and i think that's the biggest challenge
and if you look for a job where you can
learn a lot
the harder the job
the better it is and it's especially
with reality real estate so let me say
this much in macro there's four
different asset classes number one's a
business so i set out to build a
business which is a brand like warren
buffett only invests in brands like
coca-cola so rich dad became a brand
but to keep my money i had to have real
estate so let's say i make a million
dollars at rich dead i go into real
estate i borrow four million dollars and
then guys like dave ramsey are saying
get out of debt i said well it's good
for you dave but it doesn't work for me
because i hate paying taxes and i like
making money
so then the third asset class which is
stocks bonds paper mutual funds savings
i don't touch that stuff
and number five are gold silver bitcoin
and because that's where i store my
value
so when i need money i use debt
and the reason
bigger pockets you know brandon turner
and david green are here is because when
you you use debt
that is freaking dangerous
you know i was just i was just in dallas
two days like three days ago
with my partner in real estate kenny
mcelroy he was probably the smartest guy
i know i love him he's the best man he
is one smart dude and he stood up there
on stage with me and i said kenny how
much money have you borrowed this
half a year so far
300 million dollars yeah he sucked the
air out of the room
dude i mean i said well why did you
borrow 300 million dollars so the number
one would like to make money and we
don't want to pay taxes
to me that's smart so i'm still saying
buy gold silver and bitcoin
now
but will gold and servant bitcoin go up
and down of course
but that's why you want to buy the stuff
early so i'm in my my entry price for
bitcoin is 9 000.
you know
when it when it goes to let's say 20 000
i'm still in the money
so right now i'm very impressed with
bitcoin i like the blockchain idea i'm
learning more i'm an old guy but i'm
learning
but i do think it's the money of the
future
at least blockchain is going to help it
out
all these other cryptos coming out i
don't know about it i just think
my friends who are in the know tell me
that bitcoin is still the old dog the
best one to buy so but i'm not saying
buy bitcoin i'm just saying i'm buying
bitcoins a big difference
and i'm still buying gold and silver but
i started buying gold at 50 bucks
and silver at one dollar
so i'm in the money so the best time to
prepare for a crash
is before the crash
so think about this if i'm right i'm not
saying i'm right let's say they built
they blow this huge bubble you know
biting keeps handing out more stemi
checks and whatever these cartoons are
doing i mean these guys are criminals i
mean how could
you know i'm not political but trump was
building a wall in the southern border
and biden opens the gates and going
this country could not be more screwed
up
i can't believe it
you know i can't believe it
so ladies and gentlemen it's better to
be smarter
than be euphoric right now that's what
i'm saying
so i get really rich when markets crash
so
i'm watching bitcoin this is july 2021
when bitcoin gets around 27 to 24 000 i
get interested again
so that's like having neiman marcus go
on sale
so let's say i like these pair of prada
shoes so i love product shoes why
because i have fat feet they fit
comfortable
they really are comfortable
but anyway
uh what was i talking about oh so let's
say product shields at 500
nieman raises the price oh today it's
would people rush in and buy prada shoes
at 700 when they're only 500.
but that's what these idiots are doing
today
they're buying stocks at all-time highs
buying real estate at all-time highs i'm
going
everybody's happy
why do people get happy
when you're buying
assets at tops of markets
so if if i'm not saying if neiman market
says well those product shoes that were
seven hundred dollars are now on sale at
the dollar guess what i'm not going to
say oh that's terrible
the shoe price crashed no
i'm going to get really excited i'm
going to stock up on product shoes or
whatever there is you know
so ladies and gentlemen only idiots buy
at the top of a market
and today the world is full of idiots
full of idiots everybody's happy so let
me say it again this is an old old
saying in my world of investing
how did you go broke
well two ways
slowly at first
then suddenly
and i think that's my warning to you
today i'd be prepared
for the crash when bitcoin gets down to
24 i'm gonna come i'll come alive again
i'm gonna get a little bit more excited
if gold goes down to let's say a
thousand i'm gonna back up the truck
if silver goes to let's say
i'm going to back up the truck
so right now
i'm in a cash position
i'm just waiting for the crash in my
opinion all the smart guys are saying
software is your best investment
silver's 50 off this all-time high
i love silver i mean i just bought some
more i mean i don't mind i didn't i buy
silver mines
but i also buy silver coins so let me
just say my simple philosophy as a
capitalism
gold is for saving solvers for spending
so if the s has the flat fan as you know
i'm going to be spending my silver in 89
the world wide web came up so exactly as
he predicted
so all you young millennials out there
and young people you have the most
powerful tool ever created in humanity
the question is how are you going to use
it you can use that iphone the way we're
doing it right now to educate to inspire
to teach
or you can watch porno on it what's up
to you
it's really up to you it's like soccer
and rugby are two different games two
different types of players
and since my wife's a golfer you know i
play golf but i'm not i don't enjoy the
game she's fanatical
but she would be an s you know
self-employed type and all this stuff
she was going to do it on her own i i
cannot do my job on my own i cannot go
in the rugby field by myself
and when i go into the field of business
i don't go by myself bookkeeper
accountants attorneys bankers
and whoever else that's how we play the
game you know the biggest thing i can
say to any entrepreneur is
learn
be an active learner
low ego
be you know it's tough when you're
successful
because when my nylon and vertical
surface wallet business went to the moon
i was crashing down right after it
it went straight to my house
yeah it was straight to bed i thought i
walked on water except there was no
water there was only air below me
so having it the hard way you know i
don't i don't learn it easy if you've
served in the military you'll understand
what real courage is
and that was the word i got and i went
to military school in new york only
because i was such a screwed up kid in
hawaii surfing all the time
and so i needed some discipline
and when i meet people who are not
successful they lack discipline
it's not that they're not smart you know
they can't it's not save money they
can't budget money taekwondo is all all
forms legs all you know kicking
so i stuck that on my back on my head so
i went to watch the rock marines train
when they these guys they have no
feelings
they're just tough tough tough they make
great entrepreneurs though now yeah
they're nasty they're not a good guys
but you know they're tough they just go
in
so i came back to the states and i took
up taekwondo
and i still stuck at it but you know i
took it up and you have a black belt
rock come on yeah well
american black belt versus
yeah a difference in american black belt
taekwondo
and a korean black belt in taekwondo you
know so i got over there and i fight for
them for america
okay
got my amazingly
handed well let me explain to you
i was a heavyweight which means i was
fat in america
in korea they're tall and skinny like
you yeah
and koreans in taekwondo is about the
legs really
they could let's call the cheeky or the
hammer they could lift the leg straight
over their heads
and they stand there on one leg and they
just watch you
because imagine he looks like
this leg in the air
and i'm this little fat guy trying to
come up
you know how do i find an opening yeah
so i feel like you're like you can
barely get up here
i can't lift my legs
so
i get into the ring i said this is not
fair but but he's a heavyweight but he's
a skinny heavyweight right but his legs
are like no no they're really he's tall
he was like six foot four his legs were
probably eight feet high and they i
don't know how high he was up in the air
i couldn't come in on him
so i made the mistake i said well no
guts no glory
i jumped in on that leg came across my
head and i was out i got a job with
xerox because they had sales training
and then for two years i was the worst
salesman they ever had
i was going to get fired from xerox and
so i went to my rich dad and i said in
terms of why
what's wrong he says how many sales
calls you make a day i said on a good
day three
he says that's why you're not successful
same formula he says you have to fail
more
he says you got to step up your failure
rate so i found a
non-profit and at night
after working at xerox i would go to the
phone bank up the street from where i
was working in honolulu
and i had my head a goal i had to fail
35 times that night
so i just failed 35 times
now interesting thing happened
my numbers at xerox went up
you see i was handling that fear i was i
was handling the wimp in me the coward
and most people don't want to go through
the wimp
and that's why i don't really hang i
don't have much time for them do you
know why they tell you to save money
i don't know
because the system of banking york is
nothing to do with communism or
capitalism
it's the banks run the world
the rich run the world
they don't carry your communism
capitalists
so when you save so let's say you say
one dollar you as a one euro one yen
the banking system can lend out ten
so the entire system is called the
fractional reserve system
the fractional reserve system is also
printing money
and then they tell you to save money so
they they want you to save money so they
can lend out your money 10 times
so your dollar became worthless 10 times
over
and then
[Music]
they used to pay you ten percent
interest on your money now it's at best
one percent
and they're still lending it out ten
times
so that's why you don't save money is
because your money is becoming worth
less and less and less and less unless
the banks are getting richer and richer
and richer
then they tax you on that interest you
they pay you that one percent interest
if they pay you that much japan is zero
and the japanese are so stupid they
still save money
we also have zero yeah and they still
save money how stupid is that
so that's what i question so how come
that happens
now if i borrow money guess what do i
pay taxes on debt
i guess no
why is that
i know this is this is what i'm saying
okay question everything okay so when
they lend out money that's how money is
created money is debt they lend out them
why is debt tax free
i don't know
because that's how money is created
and so the banks love it they love
people borrow lots of money
so how do i get rich i borrow money
and i buy assets with it
the poor person borrows money and buys
liabilities like purses
cars houses and they get poorer and
poorer and poorer
but i use
debt i borrowed 300 million after the
crash dollars
in 2000 by 2010 i had borrowed 300
million dollars to buy real estate that
made me rich
and the interest rates kept coming down
so my cost of money kept coming down
and everybody else is saying oh you
should get out of debt you know why
because they don't question the hypnosis
they're under you've been hypnotized to
work hard for money
to save it
the fractional reserve system prints
it
and then
you pay taxes of taxes so i get i have
all this debt
and i get rich it's a great time to be
an entrepreneur because if you're smart
you have a good spirit and you you'll
learn quickly so the greatest the
greatest thing about entrepreneurs how
fast can you learn
you know when you look at the seven
deadly sins
the biggest tragedy is ego
said ego or vain glory is the road
straight to hell
and so you got to be i tell you i made
mistakes i tell you i screwed up i'm
definitely on the short list for saint
but you'd better be honest and people
trust you and they better keep your word
you know you're only as good as your
word yeah so actions and words must be
in integrity well that's why in 1997 i
created the cash flow of 96 grade the
cash flow board game it's the only game
that teaches your accounting by having
fun
so
the cash flow game i i'd play at least
10 times because each time you play
learning something new well what what
the game is doing because you have to
move move pieces and write and all this
stuff
it's moving your neural pathways you
have to train you know the most
important thing is change the neural
pathways in your brain
and and the brain is driven driven by
your heart
and when i meet somebody with an
employee's brain
they say i want job security
i want i want a good pension do that
does that medical benefits
that's their brain
it's them i can't help them
they got to rewire the brain yeah
because the economy takes place between
this year and this year that's where the
economy takes place and in your heart
and in your guts
i started playing monopoly
i was nine years old and everybody's
played monopoly
except i played in real life
you know four greenhouses one red hotel
tax-free
if you really if you're really gonna
learn to be rich you have to learn how
to sell how to use debt and how not to
pay taxes that's the game and that's why
i said when i saw that that iphone come
out i said all you millennials all you
entrepreneurs out there that cell phone
is your lifeline out of this mess
use it so what we're doing today
is anti-fragile
you know we're wartime leaders and we're
going to come out of this better i don't
know how
but it's called metamorphosis you know
metamorphosis is like when a butterfly i
mean a caterpillar turns into a
butterfly that's
metamorphosis and the definition of
metamorphosis you can look it up the
dictionary
is the tran or the transformation from
an immature form to an adult form
immature form
to adult form in other words grow up
so for some of us this crisis will grow
up will come of an anti-fragile will
come out stronger
and that's why i've been watching my
tweets i say you know the best teachers
are on youtube not in school
because most school teachers and this is
what jordan peterson is saying he said
jordan peterson's being attacked by his
own school teachers
because they are [__] you know
they're all these guys and they tend
there they job security they need
protection the world's a terrible place
capitalists are crooks and all this
stuff
and it's a free country you can listen
to those guys if you want or you can
listen to patrick mcdavid so your
thing on
the military leader versus the peacetime
leader
was prescient it was one of the most
important lessons
everybody should look at they have to
ask yourself today
am i going to be a military leader and
come out of this anti-fragile and
stronger better healthier or am i going
to be crushed
by what fuller called grunch the gross
universal cashless i encourage anybody
listening to this or any entrepreneur
get to the point where you don't need
money it's called the infinite return
and that's my my next book coming out
next year yeah when you get to the point
where you don't need money
you're home free
you'll never need money you don't care
you could always put a deal together you
can always create an asset out of
nothing you know it's like
i don't know what uh it's the power of
god-given power
so like i said when i write a book i'm
selling 50 copies 50 licenses day one
and let's say i get 10 000 a license how
much is that 50 times 10 000. 500 000.
50 times 10 000. yeah that you have
hundred thousand yeah so i'm in i'm in
the black immediately what does it cost
me maybe ten thousand to write a book
do you know so i'm in the black
the same thing if i trade a stock i buy
a stock a dollar it goes up to ten and i
sell
so i have all free trading stock i have
no money in it that's what buffett's
doing they're all infinite return guys
sure
you have no money into the deal and you
can do it with anything you know today
if you know people complain i don't make
enough money in romania well you have a
cell phone you can make money all over
the world you can't make money in
dollars yen flatnic
pesos you know
it's just limited thinking
if a person doesn't change what's inside
their head the actual thoughts running
their brain which are words
they'll never change
so the change begins when you question
go to school get a job work hard
pay taxes save money get out of debt and
invest in the stock market until you
until you question that one nothing
changes there's three kinds of income
there's ordinary portfolio passive so
when you say to some poor kid go to
school get a job
they're working for ordinary income the
highest tax income in the world
i don't work ordinary income i don't
want a paycheck
passive income is generally what happens
when you invest in the stock market
i mean portfolio income
so they say well i bought tesla at 100
it went up to 200 i sold it so i made a
hundred dollars that's portfolio income
that's taxed at the next higher level
so when i have passive income
it's tax free
getting passive income you have to know
what you're doing so that's why i have
the best
first of all bookkeeper
accountants attorneys bankers
i operate as a team just like my when we
flew into combat we're a team
and most people are trying to do it
self-employed way
you know i'm a good computer programmer
good
you pay the highest taxes you work the
hardest you don't get ahead that way
but that's what most people they want to
do it on their own you know if you want
it done right
do it by yourself
an employee is always saying the same
words you know this year and this year
i'm looking for a safe secure job
with benefits and a paycheck and uh
pension
you got that
that's what they're looking for
so if i have a job well
and a self-employed person said how are
you doing i'm the best
good i'll hire the best
but you the government's gonna penalize
you for that because you're because
you're working for a quite like blended
income
but it's more passive
it's actually ordinary income but um
pay the highest taxes the tax law are
nothing but incentives not punishments
so if you donate if i i just donated uh
money to the food bank because
throughout a lot of food as well as 10
000 bucks
i get a tax credit
i don't donate money to food bank no tax
break
so because i have 7 000 rentals in
apartment houses
i got a tax break you know why because
i'm providing housing
and because i have thousands of
employees
the tax break the government even sent
me money to pay my employees what do you
recommend people do in a market that is
potentially heading into depression
should they be saving cash
and thinking about
you know becoming more liquid like what
what are some of the things that they
should do well it depends upon the cash
if you're okay
if you're in argentine is it right peso
yeah
i wouldn't touch it
i'd say of gold and silver
see what's what's his name uh what's his
head edgewater's hedgeway no bridgewater
sky dahlia yeah he says it depends upon
the currency you're in sure he says
so like zimbabwe their debt is financed
with external money
japan is internally financed
so that's why the depression doesn't
hurt them as badly so you have to learn
so much about that
so i own millions and millions and
millions and millions of millions in
gold because i started buying gold in
1973 when it was illegal for americans
owned gold
and i like gold and silver because
there's no counterparty arrest there's
no other party to it gold and silver are
god's money
so people say well it's not a good
investment i said
yeah but
i i sleep at night what's that worth
you know sure so i don't care if the
dollar the dollar is corrupt the us
dollar is corrupt but
it's the strongest currency in a
horrible currency world yeah so if
you're u.s save dollars
you're in argentina don't save save gold
right save bitcoin you think bitcoin
would be i mean i mean bitcoin's got its
problems too but you're saying i would
so when you say save money you've got to
say what what currency yeah what
currency sure the very guys that went to
the schools the best schools created
these fake assets to make themselves and
the six major banks richer than ever
before they produced sugar highs of
immediate profits but separated those
taking the risk from those who would
bear the consequences so the way out of
it is for financial education
and you can do it everybody can do it
but you have to understand the game
after 1971 this is what happens to
people who save money the purchasing
power of the dollar is going down
because they're printing money and our
school teachers these fake teachers
again they're good people
all these financial planners still tell
you to save money well why would you
save money when these guys are printing
it faster than you could ever ever save
it
that's bad teaching
bad financial advice horrible so he says
and then the second thing they tell you
to save money and invest for the long
term in the stock market this guy is
saying i said are you nuts
this is stockman he was reagan's budget
director he is a real teacher he was
there
this is the whole stock market is rigged
for the rich again it's a casino and a
casino is based depends upon all these
losers coming in so those at the top can
win so the losers started coming in
right around here
it was a thing called the 401 k
they needed more losers to enter the
market
and what do the financial planners tell
you
save money
and invest for a long term in the stock
market they needed people to come in
here and push this up
again it's a casino like las vegas
a lot of losers walk in winners walk out
with the money that's the game now again
was glass-steagall they organized hedge
funds that turn owning a stock into a
minute to minute bit rather than invest
for the long term it's a casino we don't
know when but it will come down then all
those guys those 401ks
toast
that's why the rich dead company was
formed that's why i catch so much hell
saying savers are losers you know
why invest for a long term in the stock
market when it's a casino my concern is
my the old guys like me
are sitting there with their retirement
plans which are broke
you know
the california retirement system is
broke hawaii retirement system is broke
chicago's retirement system is broke and
if and when this baby comes down my
generation is toast
the way out is for real financial
education well number one is investing
is invest in what you love i love
business
i love real estate i mean i really love
it i own this building here
and i love gold and silver
so i invest in what i love
most people say you know and do what you
love but i rather invest in what i love
but i love being an entrepreneur i love
investing
it's like shark tank to me i'm always
looking at new businesses new deals it's
just a game like this
you know when you look at the financial
statement that's like your score card
it's like your golf scorecard is your
financial statement
but as you know our schools teach us
nothing about financial statements the
property
was a little condominium
one bedroom
one bath
eighteen thousand dollars
u.s
it was on the beach of maui
the reason the price was so low is the
market had crashed
smart investors always wait for the
crash
so this thing
crashed i had to look at 100 properties
once i left the class three-day class i
had to look at 100 properties in 90 days
and write a one-page report on each of
those properties as my instructor said
to me when i left that three-day class i
was 26 years old
and the instructor says
your education begins
when you leave the class
as your education
will begin
when you leave this class
not now
do you have a chance to talk to carlos
you have a chance to talk to alvaro
talk to them find out learn doesn't cost
you any money
change your ideas
so with this here the instructor said
i had to borrow
buy the investment for zero
money
okay
zero money
most people will tell you
i can't invest because i don't have
money
that's a loser
understand this
this was 1974.
the dollar had just gone off the gold
standard
everything was coming up fast
so
i had to figure out how to buy it for
zero
and the reason i say that is most poor
people like padre pobre always says i
can't afford it
i know some of you right now saying well
i can't afford it i don't have time i
have children i have a job i have bills
to pay and it is those excuses that keep
you poor
if you do not change that talk in your
head you will always be the poor person
so there was about 32 in my class three
days long i think only three people
completed the exercise
we went we looked at a hundred
properties
wrote a one-page report
at the end of the 90 days and 100
properties
this was the best property
so i went back to the person
and it was in bankruptcy it was right on
the beach
just as pretty as this beach here
and he said i had to have
two thousand dollars down
this is called
equity
again it's the language of money so i
have equity
the bank was going to lend me
6 000 in
debt
okay
that was the deal
now i had the 2000 in cash
but the name of the game or the exercise
was could i buy it for zero
so what i did
was i paid for this property
with a credit card
so now it was
debt okay
with that hundred percent debt
i made
twenty five thousand dollars a month
i was a free human being
i never needed money again
if you can make money with no money
that is called
an infinite return
because i have no money in the deal the
most important thing for these people
right now is choose your teachers wise
and i commend you for attempting to help
people as if i could leave anything to
you the people that are listening to you
right now commendable
they're they're looking they're looking
for answers
but it comes back down to who are your
five friends
and are you happy with it
or is it time to move on and our job is
to be wartime leaders
and be brave be courageous
get our skills up get entrepreneurial
skills up you know learn to sell learn
to communicate don't learn
my problem patrick is i infuriate people
because i attack them
being a marine
is not bright
because i like to fight
and that's why i had to go to military
school to discipline myself
so that's if any if any of you out there
you know i have young people
you know i have a lot of friends whose
sons are whips
they're just limps
they're sitting at home sucking their
thumb
and now that they lost their job they
want to go back and get a job or exactly
as you said they'll make more sitting at
home sucking their thumb
and we've lost another generation there
so it really is time to be a wartime
leader that's why you know most guys was
it every most major league athletes are
broke within six years or something they
lose everything sure or a lottery winner
yeah because money never makes you rich
and so the thing is to invest in your
life experiences your mentors so the
story of rich dad poor dad is choosing
between two different teachers
you know if i followed my poor dad i'd
probably be a government employee in
hawaii
you know or a tenured teacher yeah
so
it's it's a hard choice you gotta choose
your teachers wisely and so that's
talking to this one guys well i have a
private pilot's license
okay and then you know those guys know
it was called the big dog he was like
big dug in me i got a private private
license
i don't even have a license
but i have air metals
he didn't know what an air metal was
you know air metal just meant how many
how many round trips did you take into
combat
and came back alive that's all i mean
doesn't mean i was a hero
or anything because i wasn't you know
we're just happy to bring my crew back
alive that's all we cared about
but to get to that level of flying
is the same as investing
and i think that's what i really learned
is the dedication not to be to be the
best pilot but be the best that i could
be and if i'm not the best that i can be
people die
and a lot of people it's okay to be
average
if you know what i mean but when you get
into that situation when you're going in
and out of combat zones i went down
three times you know but i wouldn't be
back today if i hadn't practiced to be
the best
and so when i go into the world of money
and investing that i'm still not
you know i'm not
zuckerberg or those guys
but
you still have to be the best you want
you can be
and that's how i can be
you know investing in the stock market
with
diversified stock of
stock spots reach over the etfs
if you're not willing to be the best
that you can be that's the best for you
you're an average person nothing wrong
with being average
but there's something inside each of us
that wants to be the best at something
that when was reading your uh background
i think that's what you're pushing
people or asking people what do you want
to be the best at
and i just love the marine corps i hated
it when i was in it i tell you what
they're not polite
but
they demanded the best of it
so today i carry those traits
i went to military school and then i
went to you know five years of marine
corps and flying and all this
so when i hang out with my friends my
friends also want to be the best
and so in some of my
books and things i said look at the five
people you spend time with
you know if they're not striving to be
the best that's who you are too a big
lesson for you is that it's nothing to
do with the house the car the student
loan
it has to do with where's the cash
flowing
if the cash is flowing into your income
statement into your pocket
it's an asset it's good debt
but if it's taking money from your
pocket it's
bad debt about that there's good debt
in bed you're going to be successful
whether you're an employee or
entrepreneur you've got to control the
direction of your cash flow first
property there it was in maui hawaii in
the
1970s i bought it with a credit card wow
property was 18 000 my first prefer but
i've taken several real estate classes
and so i knew what to look for i found
this one property took a long time
when i found it i just broke up my
credit card and bought it and i put 25
dollars in my pocket and so that's how i
was talking you want to find your soul
where is your soul
you know what we'll sit up you know it's
like when i was when i each time i was
going down
i wasn't flying for me
i was flying for my two young gunners
you know 19 year old boys really with
kids already
if i didn't do the best job possible
taking that aircraft into the ocean
though their their kids were fatherless
and i when i meet people who don't have
it in life they don't really have that
soul in them
the soul is there don't be wrong
it's there
but you don't need it yet
so today we're aware this i think we're
going into a major depression i hate to
say that but are you prepared for it i'm
prepared for it
you know i i wrote a book called rich
dad's prophecy and i said the biggest
stock market in history was coming in
2016. so the biggest crash in world
history came in march 2020.
we're going into a depression you know
hope not
but i would say there's a 60 chance for
a depression
now for somebody with a soul and a
spirit it's the greatest opportunity in
history so these are the four words
income expense asset liability and the
last two words
are the words cash flow and that's why
the game is called
cash flow
and the secret to being rich is not a
college education but can you control
cash flow
and this is what cash flowing looks like
so this here i need this
income says asset
liability again this is you get a job
and this was my poor dad go to school
get a job get your phd
and so this here is cash flow so the
income comes in
and it goes out this way first line of
expense is tax
so this is a poor person's cash flow
pattern it's not how much money you make
most people
you know they i don't care if you have a
phd or no school at all
but they can't control the cash flowing
out through their expenses
and so that's why people like suzy orman
say cut up your credit cards live below
your means because you're a spendaholic
so that's a poor person this is a
middle-class person's cash flow pattern
and this is where the house comes in
they first thing you know most kids do
when they get pay raise or that they buy
themselves
a bigger house oh my house is an asset
now who tells you that your real estate
agent of course yeah right because they
they want to give you this false sense
of security while you're getting screwed
exactly you know but when you look at
what happens with a house a personal i
mean a personal resident something i
live in
the money comes in it goes out and this
is middle class but it also goes out
through a mortgage
mortgage payments oh but i don't have a
mortgage you still have taxes you still
you know hawaii just raised the property
taxes on me which is probably i'm going
to sell i'm going to get out of hawaii
but you have taxes and you have upkeep
so money is always flowing out
so that's why your house is not an asset
it's because it's taking money from your
pocket so very simply said
assets
put money in my pocket liabilities take
money from my pocket
and then this here is so i'm not saying
don't buy a house
but here is
a house
and
i started when i was 25
bought my first house
it was an apartment it was an investment
property
i didn't live in it i rented it out
and it put money in my pocket
so very simple the definition
of asset and liability is not the house
of this it's cash flow where is the cash
flowing so as a young person
and to all millennials or if you're old
financial intelligence is the ability to
control cash flow this is the difference
between rich and poor
the people on this side
are always trying to save money
it makes no sense to save money
because after 1971
the united states took the dollar off
the gold standard
and the dollar became debt
so that people who are saving money are
the biggest losers of all
the people who are the biggest winners
are people who know how to use debt to
get rich see debt is money
after 1971 when nixon took the dollar
off the gold standard
money became debt
and so the people who are losers are
savers
so as kenny says you put your money in
the bank as a saver
kenny goes in and borrows it out as a
debtor
and we use that money to buy millions of
dollars worth of real estate
so kenny just went over a billion
dollars worth of real estate using debt
but most people say well i can't i can't
do that because i don't have any money
you don't have any money because lesson
number one says
the rich don't work for money
so we learn to use debt to create assets
and assets keep putting money in our
pocket what is your definition of
greatness
getting up every day
at my age you gotta worry about that
stuff you know i mean
i said my plan was to die at 72.
i almost died so many times i went down
three times in vietnam and
my days were numbered from the start
i've had open-heart surgery i've had
cancer i've had pneumonia i've had
malaria
and so you know when everybody talks
about this covet 19 i said been there
done that one you know but each one of
it inspired me to get healthier
and so this crisis should inspire people
to get wealthier or you can be a loser
so i don't know why i'm going with that
but it's just
all everything bad is good
and everything good will be bad
this is called the financial statement
what makes the cash flow game different
from monopoly which my how my rich dad
taught me via monopoly
is my richard also taught me about
financial statements so the cash flow is
the only game with a financial statement
so really simply when you look at a
financial statement
there's income
expense
assets
liabilities
there's one more thing in the cash flow
game on the financial statement you'll
see
it's the most important statement of all
is called the statement of cash flow
it's off to the side here
so
if you're going to be an entrepreneur or
a capitalist
you have to have one of these
you're going to be rich you have to have
one of these but 99 of all high school
students leaving school and college have
no idea what this is you have fico
scores
you know but you don't know what this is
no
so when a banker asks you
for your financial statement
they want to see how smart you are here
so let me tell you why school
makes
students poor
so really simply is this
let's say i have a master's in
arts
master of arts degree right yeah or a
bachelor of arts degree yeah
do i learn anything about income no
what about greek mythology oh there you
go that's very important about income
and we wonder why kids are leaving
school or younger generation
looking for that high paying job
but
now let me ask you this if you have a um
a degree in technology
do you learn anything about assets
never
so you could be a techie and you know
nothing about this you could be a techie
and know nothing about this
you see when a banker looks at your
financial statement they're looking at
the mirror of you
this is a reflection of you
and if you got jack here and jack here
then you're not that smart financially
so the reason the cash flow game is such
an important game it teaches you what is
important to your banker or for a
capitalist or for an entrepreneur is
that entrepreneurs got to know how to
increase their income yeah
and
an entrepreneur has got to know how to
create assets
if you don't know those two things you
should not be an entrepreneur
you should be an employee because you
made it this far in a video i want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you are
different you are special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to get
some incredible grant cardone motivation
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there how many were
trained this competition is a healthy
thing
that message was not being delivered to
entrepreneurs
that message was being delivered to
consumers